here are the five craziest things that
Republican presidential candidates have
said about immigration number five
Bobby Jindal we must insist on
assimilation the immigration without
assimilation is an invasion we need to
tell folks who want to come here they
need to come here legally they need to
learn English adopt our values roll up
their sleeves and get to work now that
sounds reasonable until you actually
start thinking about it for more than
five seconds the United States has been
at or near the top and successfully
assimilating immigrants for decades
regardless of what it's politicians
insist on maybe Bobby Jindal should go
to one of those French suburbs he's
always talking about compare it to
Atlantic Avenue in Brooklyn and then get
back to us number for Chris Christie
because guess one of the 11 million
people who are here illegally 40% of
them didn't come in over the southern
border 40% of them came in Legally with
a visa and overstayed their visa we need
to have a system that tracks you from
the moment you come in and then when
your time is up whether it's three
months or six months or nine months or
12 months however long your visa is then
we go get you this idea which began as a
Newt Gingrich joke nearly a decade ago
faces a couple of practical obstacles
first human beings are not packages
second the Supreme Court recently ruled
that law enforcement cannot track human
beings without a warrant
third visa policies are reciprocal
meaning that what we do to foreigners
foreigners will do to us when we visit
their countries and finally what Chris
Christie is describing is a police state
number three Scott Walker well we want
to build a wall north the borders where
people have asked us about that New
Hampshire they've raised some very good
legitimate concerns including some law
enforcement folks that brought that up
to me at one of our town hall meetings
about a week and a half ago so that is a
legitimate issue for this to look at
like a lot of things Walker has said
during this campaign
he has semi walk this back but he's
hardly the only Republican candidate who
is contemplating the ridiculous number
to end Carson we need to still our
borders but not just the southern border
but the northern border the Pacific
border the Atlantic border
every border there is let me say this
slowly enough that even an
internationally renowned neurosurgeon
can understand you cannot seal a border
it can't be done you can build a hundred
foot fence along 7500 miles of land
frontier you could put a force field on
the oceans and it still wouldn't even
affect the 40% of illegal immigrants who
came to this country legally we have
visa waiver agreements with 38 countries
mean they can come in without a visa in
order to seal the border
you would have to massively disrupt
international flows of goods and human
beings with disruptions that we can only
begin to think about finally our number
one whose identity will not come as a
surprise we're going to keep the
families together we have to keep the
families together you're gonna tether up
but they have to go they have no place
to go Chuck
and either have a country or we don't
have a country let's be clear here the
GOP frontrunner is talking about
deporting American citizens we haven't
seen an idea this repulsive since World
War two when FDR forcibly locked up
japanese-americans into internment camps
if that's the path Republicans want to
go down they better learn to love the
immigration policies of President
Hillary Clinton for reason TV I'm Matt
Welch